[Música]
todos ustedes tienen su historia
favorita sobre algún desastre en un
servicio del estado sobre un enojo por
el desperdicio que hay no importa el
pasaporte que tengan todos lo hemos
sufrido pero mi nueva historia favorita
la publicó y washington post' el año
pasado y lo hizo sobre la organización
más poderosa del mundo con más acceso a
tecnología que es el pentágono
resulta que el gasto militar
norteamericano la cuarta parte se va en
gente sentada detrás de un escritorio
eso cuesta el backoffice del ejército y
en el head count prácticamente hay
un burócrata por cada soldado que tiene
el ejército más poderoso de la historia
de la humanidad
en américa latina' la ineficiencia del
estado se traduce en pobreza
se traduce también en desigualdad porque
entonces los mecanismos que hay de
redistribución no nos funcionan como
deberían funcionar y este es un lugar en
donde además se hace complicado porque
el desperdicio reina en todas partes un
estudio reciente del bid muestra que de
lo que gastamos hoy para el nivel de
eficiencia que logramos podríamos
estarlo haciendo con el 40 por ciento de
lo que se recauda o puesto de otra
manera lo que ya hoy le estamos dando al
estado podríamos darnos un 19 por ciento
de incremento en desempeño si se
hicieran mejor las cosas
ahora nosotros decimos use tecnología
eso sería lo lógico y además lo daría
mejor implementación de la regulación
más transparencia menos corrupción cosas
que de por sí son las que más influyen
en un mejor desempeño del estado para
esta es una zona segundo más donde es
curioso los pobres marchan en contra de
que se le pongan impuestos a los ricos
entonces muy difícil subir los muy malos
los servicios una enorme demanda y son
como hay una asimetría porque queremos
darle menos al estado pero que nos dé
más servicio y esa simetría la válida en
los nuevos modelos de negocios que cada
vez nos familiarizamos más con ellos
cosas como los über como nos servía en
vi en donde con el uso plataformas
tecnológicas efectivamente tenemos
mejores servicios más personalizados a
costos mucho más bajos entonces hay que
vivir con la complejidad del tema más la
asimetría que hay así que no es fácil
por más que lloremos de que el estado
funcione mejor hay que hacer algo porque
no va a pasar con simplemente exigirlo a
ideas sobre cómo organizar el estado que
son como un péndulo en algún momento
dijimos y este es max weber diciendo que
la burocracia la autoridad el orden las
normas las reglas si ordenamos y
coordinamos vamos a hacer eficientes los
desperdicios
la primera guerra mundial y luego la
segunda y alimentarle hay un estado más
grande que atendiera las necesidades de
la población
pero en los 60 70 nos fue preocupando el
levantinismo se fue haciendo cada vez
más grande más descoordinado y entonces
nos atrevemos a probar con ideas de
menos centralización y demás autogestión
más autoorganización buscando las ideas
neoliberales de los 80s en donde tal vez
se lleva a la morosidad del mercado de
la prestación de servicios públicos las
cosas iban a funcionar mejor y empezamos
a desbaratar ya es agregar el estado ya
crear agencias que compitieran unas con
otras y crear incentivos económicos de
manera que se logrará esa buscada
eficiencia y eso fue el new public
management bueno y dependiendo lo que
usted le va a encontrar muchas cosas en
contra otras a favor
pero ciertamente la historia no acabó
ahí porque conforme apareció el internet
y más capacidad computacional algunos
dijeron la solución es el gobierno
electrónico y entonces evoluciona este
gobierno electrónico en donde podíamos
usar grandes bases de datos
centralizadas de nuevo pero que el
servicio fuera distribuido a través del
internet y las nuevas herramientas pero
siempre con esta idea de que iba a
lanzar de gobierno electrónico o una
agencia central de gobierno electrónico
nos quedó todavía ese fantasma por ahí
y alguno hemos preocupo
que eso se fuera a lograr porque el
evidencia lo que muestra es que cuando
queremos hacer
desarrollos tecnológicos en el sector
privado y en cualquier otra organización
usted puede agregar muchos juguetitos
digitales
pero si no transforma la manera en que
está funcionando nunca va a ser un
maestro digital
si acaso será un fashionista está muy de
nueva se ve muy cool pero no está
haciendo nada muy distinto por otro lado
si su proceso de cambio es muy lento
tampoco lo alcanzará porque poco adoptar
las herramientas digitales así que este
camino es difícil y es difícil para cada
organización porque cada organización
tiene un punto de partida distinto
porque también los liderazgos y porque
cambian las capacidades digitales estos
casos no deberían estar sus recetas y se
nos ocurrió un grupo que eso debería
tener una guía y esa guía diría hacer
desde la perspectiva del ciudadano desde
el que consumen los servicios y
empezamos con un proyecto que fue fue
más de un proyecto académico fue
escribir un paper pero resultó
interesante empezar a crear un índice
que hoy evoluciona y estamos a punto de
hacer un lanzamiento importante con una
herramienta que va a permitir darle más
visibilidad a un índice de experiencia
de los servicios que presta el estado
por medios digitales que estamos
revisando calidad e interacción
y eso significa que puedo hacerlo en dos
días lo que obliga a una organización a
conectar sus sitios web o la manera en
que lo comparte digitalmente con sus
sistemas internos calidad de la
información y calidad del medio digital
tenemos un índice en donde esas tres
dimensiones se desglosen
porque parte de los principios
es de transparencia no es una caja negra
cualquiera puede ver cómo es que se
calculó de dónde se calculó cómo es que
está operando
busca la participación que es lo que
queríamos desde el principio desde el
paper original
a los humanos les encantan los rankings
sea de la fifa sea miss universo nos
encanta comparar ver quién va a primero
quién va de último así funciona nuestro
cerebro entonces que eso sirviera para
ponerle el spotlight a los jerarcas a
los políticos que estuvieran a cargo de
estas transformaciones pensando que si
el cambio era difícil tener la demanda
de los ciudadanos ligar el capital
político para empujar la burocracia
hacia ese cambio y la colaboración que
al hacerlo muy claro que es lo que se
está mediando y cómo se está y quién
está en qué posición no sólo el nivel
del ranking sino en los componentes del
índice que pudiera darse colaboración
horizontal
pues bien llevamos diez años con esto
y ha ido funcionando y cada vez ha ido
tomando más fuerza algunos resultados
interesantes lo que empezó con una
muestra para un estudio científico las
instituciones nos fueron pidiendo ser
evaluadas quisieron ser parte del
ranking y entonces aunque no tenemos que
pedir permiso para hacerlo porque lo
hacemos desde la perspectiva ciudadana y
desde afuera igual ha sido interesante
que las instituciones lo demanden todas
andan aquí en las paredes del venza la
curva de encaje
ahora que andan tres cuartas partes pero
sé que se comporta bien la metodología
nos tenemos aquí unos que muestran el
camino adelante y hay una cola aquí de
rezagados la parte que más les cuesta a
las organizaciones es avanzar
interacción porque después de que ya
hice bien mi sitios puede que ya curen
mi contenido ver interacción ya en la
parte de más sofisticación digitalmente
ya tengo que tener sistemas detrás con
que amarrarlo
pues bien también funcionó el llamarle
la atención a la prensa y entonces año
tras año se ha vuelto un ritual en este
país ya por estas fechas tener
la publicación del índice y entonces la
prensa una atención vaya entrevista
alcaldes y entrevistas presidentes
ejecutivos de ministros
pero bueno esa era la referencia
anecdótica como tenemos muchas
referencias de mindo ticas de
colaboración entonces quisimos usar un
poquito ciencia y de una manera más
rigurosa medir si estábamos teniendo
impacto y todos somos nuestro propio
índice para medir una administración
completa
cuatro años de un gobierno
esto es el índice de eficacia
administrativa de la contraloría general
de la república
y los puntitos verdes y rojos es la
respuesta a una pregunta que hicimos en
el segundo año de administración en
donde les preguntamos no a los políticos
del bloque de tesino de narcos sino a la
gente de ti si su jefe si la cabeza si
el jerarca trabajaba con ellos sobre una
base semanal o mensual en los proyectos
de ti y el resultado es asombroso usted
puede ser muy bueno administrativamente
puede estar invirtiendo en herramientas
si la cabeza no está involucrada
directamente en las decisiones
cotidianas de ti sencillamente no logra
llegar a ser un maestro digital pero
bueno
con este sitio lo que queremos hacer son
dos cosas uno que además de prensa y la
difusión académica vamos a poder tener
otro otro spotlight hasta ahora el
índice se ha publicado también en la
página en calle y en el gobierno digital
pero va a tener una herramienta que va a
permitir poner dos o tres o cuatro
instituciones que usted le interese y
compararse con ellas de manera que yo
pueda darme cuenta como jefe que estoy
aquí o como cualquiera otro que él esté
viendo esto que tal vez en este punto
estoy muy bien pero en este estoy flaco
pero tal vez éste está flaco aquí en
donde yo estoy bueno y el otro está bien
entonces podemos hacer un intercambio de
conocimiento y yo te ayudo donde ayudas
de una manera muy cara pero quiero
contarles dos de las historias favoritas
una vez el teatro nacional teatro
nacional en costa rica representa la
cultura de estabilidad de progreso del
siglo 19
que es curioso es un teatro muy lindo a
nivel de cualquier teatro europeo
construye una época en donde dice josé
tenía veinte mil habitantes pero
conocido por todos los costarricenses
con un centavo por cada kilo importado
así fue como se financió pero cuando el
teatro se ve entre los últimos del
ranking
a lo que pueden recurrir es a la
metáfora a su propio origen
si cuando nacimos nacimos bien porque
nos comparamos con lo mejor de europa
porque ahora vamos a comparar con
alcaldías y ministerios y se fueron de
vuelta a ver que estaba haciendo la anda
que está haciendo alemania que estaba
haciendo francia e inspirados y
aprendiendo de las mejores salas de
ópera del mundo una vez más en este
siglo vuelven a dar el salto y pasan del
fondo de la lista a la parte de arriba y
eso fue lo que movió a esta organización
muy distinto mi segunda historia que les
traigo hoy que es la contraloría general
de la república la contraloría de la
república se hizo la misma pregunta cómo
mejoramos en el ranking y ellos que
tenían acceso a datos
toda la contabilidad de costa rica
socorre sobre s&p toda la contabilidad
está en línea porque no pegamos entonces
todas las compras del sistema de compras
y lo hacemos visible al público y
montaron una capa de esas intelligence y
cualquiera puede entrar y ver en tiempo
real que se le está comprando a quien si
se la dedico a alguien es algo en esta
mañana ya está visible y contra quien
compitió y quién es el que le compra y
ustedes siguen años quiere ven ustedes y
de ver que la información cruzada como
que una nombre me transparencia una
nueva flexibilidad pero aquí es donde
viene la parte y el llamado a la acción
en esta tarde
cuando solo cuento un costarricense la
expresión casi siempre de sorpresa y eso
tiene cuatro años de ser así
no se vale que simplemente le exijamos
al estado y le exijamos el estado pero
no seamos capaces de poder ponerle
atención a las cosas que se están
haciendo bien y aplaudir las y usar ese
poder que tenemos sobre los ciudadanos
de comunicar y difundir las cosas cuando
también se están haciendo bien así como
debemos a las autoridades exigibles que
estén usando lo digital y apuntarlos y
ayudarles en la dirección correcta
diciéndoles nosotros qué es lo que nos
gusta qué es lo que realmente queremos
que muevan sus acciones y sus
inversiones el mundo que viene va a ser
más asimétrico o lo menos va a ser más
complejo va haber más incertidumbre
difícilmente pensar en un shark que guíe
toda la transformación en una mente
poderoso va a funcionar necesitamos
saberlo bien inspirarnos en la
naturaleza y así como las hormiguitas
sin tener un jefe que les diga cómo son
capaces de construir este palacio así
también nosotros cada uno como
ciudadanos haciendo un consumo
inteligente de los servicios que nos da
el estado por medios digitales podamos
lograr
información del estado para todos
nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]